Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Schon gehört es gibt jetzt öffnungsdatum orgien.
Lass uns beide mal lieber eine korona diskussions- feiern.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundert unter zweiundvierzig im jahre des herrn vierundzwanzigster april zwanzig
und ist immer noch korona überall und aber wir können uns jetzt wieder ein bisschen locker machen habe ich gehört.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob du hast du sicherlich mitbekommen denn donald trump hat ja jetzt die lösung
also corona ist bald vorbei und zwar mit hilfe von desinfektionsmittel und uv-licht welches innerhalb des körpers angewendet werden muss.
Mit anderen worten,
diese gesamte trump geschichte wird sich jetzt relativ bald erledigt haben durch einen angeleiteten kollektiven suizid seiner anhänger.
Da hoffen wir es schon länger drauf euch habe das mal ausprobiert habe mich meine weile hier auf meinem solarium in mein solarium gelegt und.
Nein von innen tim du musst du musst dir.
Domes getrunken.
Ich habe mir ich habe mir nur eingeführt.
Das licht muss ja auch von innen kommt gott oh.
Also in meinem in meinem körper findest du kein korona virus.
Den rest habe ich mit mit runtergespült also das geht jetzt weiter als nächstes injiziere ich mir noch ein bisschen chlor gleiche.
Und dann ist das ganz ganz easy ne.
Die sache läuft.
Das das ist wirklich einer der schönsten momente es gibt da so aufzeichnungen die das gesicht
der wissenschaftlerin die den donald trump da berät zeigen während er das sagt,
und du siehst wie so alle guten geister aus der amt frau fahren die jetzt ja quasi am höhepunkt ihrer karriere dem präsidenten in der pandemien beraten darf und der sagt jo ich habe gesagt wir leuchten einfach mit uv-licht von innen in den körper und gießen
und spritzen desinfektionsmittel ein und du siehst nur wie die da sitzt und du merkst dass man die arme frau ey ja bitter.
Es ist bitte.
In logbuch freiheit haben wir uns übrigens gerade dieses die aufzeichnung war gerade der polizeigewalt gewidmet.
Ein bisschen über polizeigewalt gesprochen logbuch freiheit wie gesagt unser kleiner beitrag von lea beckmann und mir zur,
united stream und ich würde sagen so langsam findet sich das format wir haben's jetzt geschafft dass in ich glaube knapp mit einer viertelstunde hinzukriegen und freue ich mich nach wie vor über abonnenten und abonnenten.
Du musst noch auf zehn minuten drücken sonst ist das alles nicht aufmerksamkeit kompatibel.
Ach ey wenn der trosten halbe stunde über irgendwelche belanglose stimmt natürlich.
Ja hast du immer noch eine maske auf.
Diesmal habe ich keine maske mehr auf weil man wird ja jetzt wieder leichtsinnige,
leute sind wieder auf der straße und wir feiern dass er null komma hast du nicht gesehen und um um diese allgemeinen sorglosigkeit und freude nachdruck zu verleihen habe ich heute dann keine maske auf.
Also ich würde sagen wenn du das wirklich noch richtig zum erfolg führen willst ne ohne jump carts kannst du sagen nicht vergessen na also das ist ganz wichtig sonst ist das ja wie podcast und podcast müssen wir ja alles total langweilig.
Ja das wird sie nicht durchsetzen.
Okay also like und glocke und haste nicht gesehen und empfehlt uns auf facebook weil wir können das nicht weil wir nicht auf facebook sind.
Schnell weiter zum nächsten blog.
Genau und und regt euch bitte auch schön weiter in den kommentaren darüber auf dass ich ein video auf youtube veröffentliche denn auch das muss kritisch reflektiert werden und dafür brauchen wir euch.
Was fällt dir überhaupt ein linos was fällt dir überhaupt ein.
Das ist diese diese corona sorglosigkeit und angst die uns hier ins verderben führt.
Ich hatte das in der letzten sendung angekündigt dass der c etwas zur.
Datenspeicher app des veröffentlicht das ist auch passiert.
Link findet ihr in den shownotes primäre,
technische analyse von martin cheers ich und patrick jäger und da gibt's drei sehr interessante aspekte die in dieser app aus technischer perspektive gefunden wurden erstens.
Die app dient eigentlich nur dem.
Ermöglichen des zugangs über tons also geschrieben.
Sind es im prinzip so 'ne.
Dauerhaft zugangs einrichtungs- möglichkeit wenn jetzt zum beispiel was was viele vielleicht benutzen so ein dritter klein wo man dann wenn man jetzt so eine app hat dann gibt man da einmal das passwort ein.
Die app kriegt aber gar nicht das passwort die meldet sich also nicht mit dem passwort an sondern die kriegten token,
mit dem sie sich anmeldet man könnte sagen die kriegt ihr eigenes langes kleines geheimnis mit dem es auf diese app von twitter dann zugreifen kann.
Ja so ein temporärer zweitschnitt sozusagen.
Genau beziehungsweise natürlich der kann genauso gut dauerhaft sein und der übersteht dann natürlich auch zum beispiel eine passwort änderung wenn ihr jetzt auf twitter euer passwort ändert,
der token bleibt im zweifelsfall gültig vorteil ist aber auch ihr könnt unter tokens dann zum beispiel diese.
Zugänge auch wieder entziehen ist immer ganz interessant mal bei twitter reinzuschauen auf wie vielen clients man da inzwischen schon zugang verteilt hat diese technologie.
Kommt hier bei dieser app zum ansatz bei wenn ich das richtig verstehe allen fitnesstracker aus herr.
Dem apple health und das bedeutet diese app selber die datenspezialisten holt gar nicht die daten von eurem fitnesstracker-armband oder die hat nur die funktionalität einem server des.
Zugriff auf eure cloud daten zu geben.
Das bedeutet aus dieser cloud kann sich dann der server auch die fitness daten vor beginn der spende holen und,
wenn ihr jetzt einfach naiv davon ausgeht ich installiere die datenspeicher.
Dann spende ich nicht mehr ist das falsch weil der hat ja einen token und holt sich die quasi dauerhaft ich hatte das ja in der letzten sendung schon gesagt das ist im prinzip so 'ne einzugs ermächtigung die man da dann eben kippt ist.
Kann,
für eine informierte nutzerin völlig in ordnung sein sollte aber natürlich sinnvoll dort auch erklärt werden das zweite was dann bemängelt wird über diesen token.
Den,
den man dann hier dieser dem server gibt können nicht nur die daten abgerufen werden sondern auch die klarnamen das heißt,
der zugriff den ihr mit dieser app dann dem server gebt ist nicht die lösung findet erst auf den seiten,
statt im nachhinein ja oder dadurch dass sie den namen nicht abrufen oder nicht speichern sie haben aber in zugriff darauf.
Und dann gibt's noch da kommen wir dann in den weiteren technischen bereich so möglichkeiten von männern bemittelt angriffen weil die die zertifikate nicht korrekt checken bei den bei den zugriffen,
und die daten werden nicht sicher gespeichert also es gibt.
Möglichkeiten auf einem telefon zugangsdaten in einer
in einem in einer sequenz cleveren trusted plattform model oder im kiez unterzubringen und man kann es eben auch falsch machen und die einfach irgendwo ins dateisystem schreiben wo
potenziell sie auch einfacher von anderen gelesen werden können also auch hier einiges an sorglosigkeit all.
Immerhin wurde aber nicht der ganze server mit seinen vierhunderttausend zugang zugangs tons aufgemacht obwohl auf dem gleichen server noch ein ungepflegte wordpress liegt also insgesamt würde ich jetzt mal so sagen.
Eine kombination an best practice verletzungen und schwachstellen die,
korrigiert sind ja und deswegen wurde der bericht dem l k i und diesem dienstleister den sie da verwendet haben oder den sie da beauftragt haben auch ein paar tage vorher zugesandt
damit sie sich daran machen können diese fehler zu beheben.
Wenn ich dann mal.
Kurz hinzufügen darf um eine rolle als apple fanboy da auch gerecht zu werden kurze erklärung warum das mit apple hältst nicht so ist wie mit den anderen fitnesstracker weil's da keine wolke gibt wo diese daten drin sind sind einfach,
lokale daten auf dem telefon das heißt die app muss dort den zugriff haben es gibt die nirgends woanders und muss von dort vom telefon das quasi ans übermitteln und wenn man halt die app löscht dann gibt's natürlich auch den zugriff nicht mehr.
So dann.
Das haben wir am montag mittag veröffentlicht diese analyse mit einer pressemitteilung wie das eben so üblich ist und dann gab es einen einen artikel in der faz.
Und zwar wurde der geschrieben von einem herrn konstantin van linden.
Der dann doch da einige sehr interessante sachen geschrieben hat es ging irgendwie los mit dass nach angaben des c unabhängig erstellte gutachten
texte aha also so eine klassische wir ziehen das jetzt mal per se in zweifel dass das gutachten unabhängig ist weil,
man sich natürlich bei der faz nicht vorstellen kann dass drei personen insgesamt vom c.
Ehrenamtlicher kapazität in ihrer freizeit unbezahlt so eine app kontrollieren und diese ergebnisse ihrer sicherheitsanalysen dem hersteller geben.
Und dann nachher auch noch veröffentlichen ja dann,
wir steht ja weiterhin also es werden dann nach und nach die befunde in zweifel gezogen ja von einem menschen wo ich jetzt vorsichtig sagen würde dem.
Wahrscheinlich das schreibt er auch selber in diesem bericht,
die kompetenz fehlt die tatsächlich zu beurteilen fast schon bizarre wirkt es etwa wenn der cfc auf etlichen seiten darstellt wie es einem angreifer der zugriff auf das gerät eines nutzers hat
gelingen kann einzelne daten aus der datenspeicherung auszulesen,
ja das ist eben der befund nummer drei dass die eben unsicher gespeichert sind ne und da hat er also da hat er halt auch nicht ganz verstanden dass das,
zugang zugriff auf das gerät eben auch bedeutet remote zugriff wenn du eine andere app kompromittiert hast oder eine andere bösartige app ist.
Aber besonders stark ist dann folgende folgende satz.
Der sich in der ursprungsdefinition dieses artikels befindet und da denke ich muss man durchaus mal darauf eingehen also situation ist die haben drei leute eine sicherheitsanalysen gemacht von einer app die zu dem zeitpunkt vierhunderttausend menschen nutzen.
Wo eben.
Im zweifel gesundheitsdaten oder fitness daten von leuten auf ein zentralen server über zu übertragen werden.
Ich zitiere an dieser stelle wird auch die mitunter etwas problematische rolle des c bei gutachten dieser art erkenntlich der verein bietet seine dienste schließlich auch im vorfeld der veröffentlichung einer app an freilich gegen geld.
Falsch das zitat geht weiter behörden die darauf verzichten.
Könnten später das pech haben in den fokus der hacker zurück wobei dann jeder noch so obskure realitätsferne und nur unter unverhältnismäßigem aufwand zu schließen der angriff viktor
dokumentiert wird und
lieber herr von linden das ist natürlich schon ein ganz schön starkes stück eine derartige behauptungen in den raum zu stellen weil nichts anderes wird hier unterstellt als erpressung und eben,
unsaubere motive dabei wenn hier drei personen sich ehrenamtlich hinsetzen unbezahlt.
Ein ich glaube fünfundzwanzig sechsundzwanzig seitiges seitigen bericht formulieren ja ich
habe jetzt nicht genau nachgefragt wie viel arbeit da rein geflossen ist aber das sind schon so,
eins zwei drei personen wochen die in so einem bericht stecken ja und dann öffentlich diffamiert zu werden dass man irgendwie ein erpresser sei er das ist natürlich ziemlich übel insbesondere natürlich dann auch noch,
der falsch unterstellung der chaos computer club biete seine dienstleister leiste leistung gegen geld an das ist nicht nicht richtig dass eine falsch darstellung dies auch nachweislich falsch und die durfte der autor dann auch korrigieren in,
mitglieder des vereins bieten ihre dienste an und.
Zu den weiteren aspekt dass wenn man einerseits eine sicherheitsanalysen gegen geld bekommen kann
und andererseits eine sicherheitsanalysen wenn sich ehrenamtliche finden kostenlos ja
das ist natürlich das kein nachteil sondern das ist das positive wirken des chaos computer clubs das ist das ziel dem wir uns alle hier seid nunmehr als
nun mehr als drei jahrzehnten widmen die verantwortung des verantwortungsbewusstsein in technik
zwischen im spannungsfeld zwischen technik und gesellschaft irgendwie zu wahren und wahrzunehmen und ich finde das auf eine weise sehr unterhaltsam ja dass dass es hier einen menschen in seiner phantasie nicht
möglich ist zu erkennen dass hier einfach mal leute ehrenamtlich im interesse der gesellschaft etwas positives beitragen wollen sondern er sofort bösartige.
Motivation unterstellen muss fakt ist ja dieser bericht ist.
Quasi vorher schon an an und den hersteller gegangen damit die den begegnen können und interessanterweise.
Das haben sie auch denn der autor schreibt selber in seinem ja,
ja sehr kritischen verriss dieser studie dass er den text vorab hatte und von uns hat er den nicht
und er hat uns auch keine fragen dazu gestellt mit anderen worten man kann nur darüber mutmaßen wieder dieser fatz outdoor der
verschwörungstheorien und unwahrheiten die ihr nachher korrigieren muss über den c verbreitet
ausgerechnet an diese sicherheitsanalysen gekommen ist die ja eigentlich nur in den händen des c und des der betroffenen unternehmen war das ist schon sehr.
Bedauerlich ansonsten sei noch anzumerken diese datenspeicher app hat um die vierhundertfünfzigtausend euro gekostet,
was für eine software dieser dieser größe und qualität dann doch sage ich mal auf jeden fall kein schnäppchen war,
und ausgerechnet irgendwie drei leute vom c die sich bemühen das ding zu reviewen und einen kostenlosen bericht dazu beisteuern das sind dann auf einmal die bösen also,
da muss man wirklich sagen da ist der gute herr von linden linden,
wirklich auf einem auf einem ganz schönen traurigen holzweg gelandet.
Also ich muss sagen ich finde finde diesen absatz den zur hälfte zitiert hast es kanal löst und auch die änderung in mitglieder des vereins ändert da ehrlich gesagt herzlich wenig dran weil es ja dann immer noch
in irgendeiner form insinuieren sozusagen ist jetzt bei uns im club,
leute gibt die sie sicherheitsanalysen verstehen dass man so ein öffentliches gutachten macht,
meinetwegen dann auch kostenlos ja indem man sagt alles ganz schlimm alles ganz schlimm und dann führt er ja noch aus weil die wenigsten
hat er geschrieben noch nicht mal ordentlich
gegen gelesen weil die wenigsten journalisten oder leser technisch in der lage sind zwischen wirklich gravierenden sicherheitslücken und eher herbei geschriebenen gefahren zu unterscheiden
entsteht dann schnell der eindruck die untersuchte anwendung sei ja katastrophal unsicher,
auch wenn viele der beschriebenen gefahren sich kaum je realisieren dürfen,
also nach dem motto also klare unterstellung dass immer alles aufgeblasen ist und dass das dann sozusagen so so ja wir haben es jetzt mal überhaupt net so jetzt kannst du ja noch mal ein bisschen geld zahlen dann nehmen wir das wieder zurück oder was also.
Absolut lächerlich und und weißt du und und das muss man vor dem hintergrund sehen ne dass er hat dann server,
auf dem befinden sich jetzt wenn man mal also wenn sie sagen sie haben vierhunderttausend nutzer
ja jetzt nehmen wir mal fünfundzwanzig prozent apple weg dann sind da dreihunderttausend tokens die direkt zugriff auf nutzernamen.
Und komplette fitness daten.
Zulassen ja und auf dem server wo diese token liegen da ist auch noch ein altes ungepflegte wordpress das wollte ich nicht erwähnen.
Weil so ein altes ungepflegt des wordpress müsst ihr euch ungefähr so vorstellen wie so eine alte ungepflegte tür und.
Das ist da ist wirklich der falsche moment für große fresse ja und na ja also ich denke.
Das ist wirklich ein ein ein etwas eher peinlicher schuss in den ofen hier und ich find's aber insbesondere also quasi
ich meine dass dass er nicht in der lage ist die die technischen hintergründe vollständig zu beurteilen und zu verstehen ist nicht schlimm dafür machen wir unsere öffentlichkeitsarbeit dafür hätten wir ja auch bei fragen zur verfügung gestanden wenn ihn unsere meinung interessiert hätte.
Und der.
Die verschwörungstheorien die da entfaltet werden nun da muss man natürlich sagen der c ist älter als der autor,
und irgendwie irgendetwas was in richtung erpressung oder sonstiges hier geben würde hat sich der cfc bisher nicht zu lasten kommen lassen ich kann würde ich vielleicht ganz kurz noch mit anmerken.
Ich habe das schon öfter mal anklicken lassen es ist wenn man im bereich der it-sicherheit und,
im bereich des politischen engagements tätig ist nicht unbedingt von vorteil.
Quasi mit dem c assoziiert zu sein also es ist nicht so dass ich
feststellen würde besonderen beruflichen vorteil
dadurch zu haben dass ich sage hallo ich möchte ihnen meine dienste anbieten ich bin vom c ja das ist also eher das natürlich einer liberalen organisation dann eher mit argwohn begegnet wird.
Und jetzt
zum glück ist es nicht ganz so schlimm dass ich versuchen muss leute zu erpressen denn gerade der bereich der it-sicherheit auch das hätte der herr von linden von linden recherchieren können da herrscht ja ein derartiger personalmangel und ein derartiger,
überschuss an aufträgen das mit sicherheit jeder in dem bereich kompetente.
Eine lukrative verwendung seiner zeit hätte als ehrenamtlich irgendwelche apps zu zu reviewen und.
Dass jeder ein job findet ohne andere zu erpressen das ist also
ja also da tut mir leid aber da muss man sich dann wirklich mal gegen solche hanebüchenen unterstellungen und diffamierungen und verschwörungstheorien der nichts anderes ist das muss man sich da glaube ich schon mal sehr klar
zur wehr setzen nicht zuletzt hat der chaos computer club hier nichts anderes gemacht als und eine dienstleistung zu schenken.
Die sicherlich viele tausend euro gekostet hätte insbesondere wenn man weiß man redet von der app die hier in insgesamt eine volumen von vierhundertfünfzigtausend euro hatte das ist also da ist der herr.
Von linden bisschen auf dem holzweg gewesen tja.
Wer auch offen holzweg ist inzwischen ist leider leider leider die debatte über,
contact tracing ich habe das ja in der letzten sendung schon so ein bisschen erläutert was da jetzt gerade an kräfte verhältnissen stattfindet ich fasse das nochmal kurz zusammen.
Wir haben im prinzip drei player das sind einmal die regierung und staaten das sind unabhängige.
App-entwickler innen die irgendwelche konzepte entwickelt haben sei das in österreich sei das in deutschland sei das.
In der schweiz sei das viele unterschiedliche arbeitsgruppen und forschungsgruppe in unterschiedlichen ländern und es gibt,
google und apple die,
am gründonnerstag einen ersten vorstoß zu einem dezentralen konzept gemacht haben und die rolle von google und apple bei einer realisierung eines solchen konzeptes.
Kann gar nicht überschätzt werden denn was.
Sie haben den schlüssel dazu dass sich das überhaupt umsetzen lässt was irgendjemand vorhat weil beide betriebssysteme bei apple sehr viel mehr als bei android die.
Die abiturienten umsetzung einer contact tracing app mehr oder weniger verhindern also das was irgendwie diskutiert wird als peppi d p.
Und sonst was ist auf der apple plattform nicht möglich solange es nicht solange nicht apple ausnahmen zulässt und was wir in der letzten woche schon erzählt haben apple und google haben sich jetzt zu einem dazu entschieden.
Im prinzip die gesamte funktionalität von contact racing in die betriebssysteme reinzubringen und.
Nur eine abstrahiert.
Den apps zur verfügung zu stellen das hat auch das in der letzten sendung schon besprochen den vorteil dass sie damit ein weltweit einheitlichen ansatz haben und den app-entwicklern.
Relativ viele möglichkeiten dinge falsch zu machen einfach gar nicht erst bieten es hat den nachteil,
für diese app-entwickler dass sie jetzt das was sie sich mal ausgedacht haben nicht unbedingt umsetzen können weil eben apple und google jetzt einen weltweiten standard mehr oder weniger,
unterstützen und entscheidend ist dieser standard.
Ist ein dezentraler standard also einer bei dem es keine zentrale instanz gibt die die kontakte der nutzerinnen track alarmiert oder überhaupt mitgeteilt bekommt sondern es werden,
die codes der infizierten hochgeladen und der abgleich ob man sich ob man alarmiert werden wird oder nicht findet auf dem telefon statt im vergleich zu einem zentralen ansatz wo das alles auf einem,
zentralen server stattfinden würde das ist die situation.
Und vor diesem vor diesem hintergrund haben eben in der letzten woche ja schon einige
der streitereien der ansätze begonnen ja wo die forschergruppen sich gegenseitig vorwürfe gemacht haben und ihre ich denke ihre fachdezernaten in die öffentlichkeit getragen haben was
auf eine weise eben bedauerlich ist weil diese fachdezernaten bei aller liebe im moment keine.
Relevanz mehr haben zumindest ab dann wenn apple und google sagen so läuft der hase und so läuft er nicht wie siehst du das tim.
Ja das ist das ist natürlich das ding ich meine der der druck auf die beiden unternehmen ist natürlich relativ groß.
Aber ich denke dass sie dem einfach auch standhalten werden weil sie relativ überzeugt von ihrem ansatz sind wie ich finde auch aus gutem grund und ich finde auch nach wie vor den.
Den ausblick hier an international eine internationale kompatibilität aller lösungen zu haben der ist absolut zu begrüßen weil es ist halt kein rein lokales problem.
Überraschend an der sache ist ja dass apple und google hier einen dezentralen ansatz verfolgen obwohl man ja eigentlich sagen kann.
Die sind eigentlich nichts scheu daten ihrer nutzer zu sammeln und ich glaube übrigens ich glaube dass eine überlegung dabei eine sehr große rolle für die gespielt haben wird die werden sich überlegt haben.
Naja wir könnten das auch zentral machen dann traut der ganzen wurst keiner das ist ja das kernargument für den dezentralen ich glaube aber auch dass sie sich überlegt haben ey,
weißt du was wenn wir jetzt einen zentralen ansatz bauen ja in dieser eile mit dieser mit diesem zeitlichen druck und so und es geht uns da irgendetwas schief und das ding fliegt uns um die ohren ja das risiko wollen wir einfach nicht haben,
wir wollen das risiko gar nicht erst haben und das ist der dass der kern der auseinandersetzung zwischen dem zentralen und den dezentralen ansatz.
Ich möchte hier auch an dieser stelle nochmal betonen ich bin der festen überzeugung dass auch die vertreterin eines zentralen ansatzes nichts böses im schilde führen
ich glaube nicht dass da irgendwo einer sitzung sagt jetzt machen wir die die böse überwachung der menschheit oder so ja ich glaube dass die einfach andere abwägung haben die
kennen die risiken der der anonymisierung genauso die sind auch bemüht den zu begegnen ich halte es nur aus fachlicher perspektive für sinnvoller ein risiko was ich gar nicht erst habe.
Mir was ich nicht haben muss mir gar nicht erst einzutreten ja also besser als dem risiko.
Zu begegnen ist es gar nicht erst zu haben und ich habe jetzt kürzlich dazu auch nochmal in verschiedenen presse-interview so gesagt komplexität ist eben der feind von it-sicherheit.
Und dieser zentrale ansatz wird einfach dadurch dass er sich viel mehr risiken auflädt viel komplexer und damit eben auch,
potenziell riskanter und unsicherer und deswegen versucht man in der it-sicherheit immer möglichst.
Die einfachste lösung zu gehen denn da wo es komplex wird da gehen die sachen schief und.
Ich kann mir an dieser stelle nicht verkneifen zu sagen namen du.
Aber wir hätten natürlich nicht die wir werden nicht in der bundesrepublik deutschland wenn nicht.
Die bundesregierung fundamentale anteile der realität einfach ignorieren würde.
Denn jens spahn hat nun.
Verlauten lassen dass er sich für einen zentralen ansatz interessiert und es mehren sich die berichte dass die bundesregierung jetzt eben auch druck ausüben möchte auf google und apple.
Diesen zentralen ansatz zu ermöglichen also mit anderen worten ihre.
Ihren dezentralen ansatz irgendwie aufzuweichen den apps mehr rechte für einen zugriff zu geben um so dann auch eine zentrale analyse zu ermöglichen.
Good luck.
Interessant ist wir haben heute ein bisschen pressearbeit dazu gemacht dass du jetzt irgendwie so also die sagen wir mal die regierungs freuen.
Systemmedien die bringen dann sowas an wie ja die app muss jetzt schnell her und der datenschutz die datenschutz bedenken die töten hier und wer interessant ist wenn du dieses argument vorbringt ja wenn du sagst.
Die app muss jetzt schnell her und der datenschutz steht denn im weg.
Dann bist du leider mit einem klammerbeutel gepudert denn wenn du jetzt als regierung sagst wir brauchen so schnell wie möglich so eine app und die muss ordentlich sein dann nimm doch den ansatz von apple und google die weisen doch den weg,
ja also ich glaube dass es hier in mehrfacher hinsicht.
Unsinnig ist jetzt noch gegen den widerstand von apple und google ein zentralen ansatz verfolgen zu wollen während die lösung von apple und google auf dem tisch liegt.
Also mein eindruck die gesamte deutsche debatte ist jetzt vollkommen entgleist und findet in einem bereich statt der dem eben die.
Der realitätsbezug immer weiter abhanden kommt.
Ja du musst das verstehen der ber ist jetzt abgenommen da muss dann mal wieder ein neues projekt her was man ewig verschleppen und verkacken kann.
Ja ich meine brauchen wir uns nichts vor darauf läuft's hinaus also zentrales modell nützlich oder nicht nützlich hin und her kann ja alles sein ja also selbst selbst wenn es segensreiche vorteile hätte es gibt halt den punkt erstens
es ist einfach in der aktuellen situation absolut nicht realistisch davon auszugehen dass man die technische basis dafür erhalten würde,
bei apple und google weil die da einfach nicht mitmachen werden aus wie ich finde sehr guten gründen und zweitens ist die komplexität dieses zentralen modells also einfach der ganze.
Kram der da jetzt gebaut getestet und im betrieb zuverlässig laufen müsste.
Der ist so absurd groß das dauert monate wenn's richtig richtig richtig gut läuft monate bis das fertig ist,
und und dann ist internationale kompatibilität nochmal nochmal eine frage die auch überhaupt noch nicht so richtig geklärt ist das ist zwar irgendwie so theoretisch da so vorgesehen und so und könnte vielleicht auch funktionieren aber
wichtiger ist jetzt einfach eine einen technischen standards weltweit am besten auch noch die ganzen,
anderen überwachen staaten auch noch dazu bekommen dass sozusagen aus dem druck heraus auch noch zu akzeptieren dass sogar china einsehen muss dass sie da sozusagen mitspielen müssen,
weil sie irgendwann ja auch mal wieder ihr ihr volk durch die welt schicken will um business zu machen oder eben auch leute vor ort hat und auch davon profitieren würde und das das wäre eigentlich jetzt das wo man sein politisches gewicht dahinter werfen muss
dass sie das noch nicht verstanden haben finde ich in gewisser hinsicht also einerseits nicht,
nicht wirklich überraschend weil so können wir sie ja aber in dieser situation wo sie ja doch eigentlich zumindest was jetzt die
die viro logen und epidemiologische betrifft durchaus auch mal auf begonnen haben auf stimmen zu hören die von ihrem fach was verstehen ja dass das leider im computer bereich immer noch nicht soweit ist.
Also wir wünschen uns auf jeden fall dass angela merkel sich jetzt diese corona app diskussionen auch noch verbietet ja das denke ich kann man so festhalten ich würde noch gerne einen kleinen hinweis darauf erlauben.
Insgesamt sind diese diskussion bis letzte woche.
Eigentlich sehr gut gelaufen die diskussion über corona apps ja wir haben ich habe das ja schon öfters gesagt wir sind angefangen mit irgendwelchen ps überwachung wir haben echt feine,
ansätze jetzt die sogar noch in rekordgeschwindigkeit nah sind an der
an der projekt reif an der an der produktionsraum es ist also es sieht alles echt gut aus aber es wird sich halt durch diese diskussion gerade komplett kaputt gemacht und diese diskussion gehen am ziel vorbei ein beispiel.
Ich wurde von der wirtschaftswoche interviewt und habe,
in dem kontext ja das war so ein etwas längeres interview wo ich einfach mal die situation einordnen sollte ja und dann habe ich in diesem interview gesagt.
Wo wir über die beiden ansätze gesprochen haben zentral dezentral habe ich gesagt der vorteil,
des zentralen ansatzes wenn der zentrale server beispielsweise beim robert-koch-institut stünde könnten die epidemiologische
dort eine hochrechnung erstellen wie sich die infizierten zahlen entwickeln schließlich erfahren sie so wie viele kontakte ein infizierte hat in einem bestimmten zeitraum hatte.
Der nachteil.
Es gibt eine zentrale instanz die wissen kann wer wann den getroffen hat und das ist ein erheblicher eingriff in die privatsphäre,
schwächt das vertrauen gerade weil man dem zentralen server vertrauen muss wie gesagt mein credo
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser und wir möchten so wenig wie möglich vertrauen müssen jetzt ist folgendes mit diesem interview passiert es wurde nur der erste teil,
in einem weiteren artikel zitiert nämlich der teil wo ich den vorteil eines zentralen ansatzes schildere.
Das wiederum hat dann die die ja wie soll man das sagen also die die die twitter also leute wo ich überrascht war dass sie überhaupt soweit den artikel gelesen haben sagen wir mal so sofort rausgepickt und dann irgendwie so da der cfc ist aber jetzt für zentral weil
der neumann führt ja hier ein argument auf für den zentralen ansatz ja
kinder selbstverständlich würdige ich auch ein vorteil eines modelles gegen das ich bin das ist ja vollkommen also es gehört ja zu einer zu einer debatte,
abseits von twitter durchaus dazu ja dem einem einem konkurrierenden ansatz den man jetzt nicht favorisiert durchaus auch mal seinen vorteil zuzugestehen um dann eben zu sagen
in welchem mit welchen nachteilen dieser vorteil abgewogen werden muss das und solche grad solche.
Twitter ergüsse wo dann irgendwelche leute los palaver ja und irgendwie der cfc ist jetzt für zentral an sowas merkt man dann.
Leider dass die debatte eben den.
Ja die sachlichkeit jetzt wieder verloren hat und bis bisher hatte ich den eindruck dass die eigentlich.
Sehr gut verlaufen ist in der in der interessierten fachärztliche und ich muss leider.
Traurig feststellen dass sie inzwischen viel an ihrer qualität verloren hat.
Insbesondere seitdem jetzt einzelne projekte da angegriffen werden und irgendwie teuflische machenschaften unterstellt werden das war vor zwei wochen irgendwie besser diese auseinandersetzung.
Orgen wir wollen orgien.
Eine orgie kann halt mit zunehmender dauer auch einfach mal ein bisschen angestrengter werden und das beobachten wir jetzt gerade.
Ja vielleicht noch ein kurzes,
update zu wie ist denn da aussieht bei dieser technischen situation bei diesem google apple google protokoll von dem man aber nicht so genau weiß wie man es denn eigentlich bezeichnen soll
und das ist jetzt auch sagen wir mal etwas was ich jetzt geändert hat reiter heißt jetzt fix das kontext
tracing protokoll wurde jetzt umbenannt in export tracing offensichtlich hatte man so den eindruck bestätigen dass die leute irgendwie
mit dem wort kontakte in den protokoll nahm so ein bisschen ihre probleme haben
naja die url hat es noch der titel der webseite hat es noch aber die ganzen protokoll spezifikationen wurden jetzt umgeschrieben und es heißt also jetzt,
pokert tracing.
Da ganz kurz stolz was anbringt tim,
in meinem blogpost vom märz ja indem ich da den dezentralen ansatz formuliere habe ich spezifisch schon von exposition gesprochen.
Zitat der abgleich der veröffentlichten mit den lokal auf meinem handy gespeicherten codes ermöglicht das berechnen meiner exposition,
dabei ist es unerheblich ob ich zehn stunden mit einer infizierten person verbracht habe oder jeweils zwanzig halbe stunden mit unterschiedlichen infizierten personen selbst das kann aus den daten nicht rekonstruiert werden also,
exposition dezentrale ansatz.
Hast du schon drauf gehabt ne.
Die haben alle bei mir abgeschrieben.
Ja ja wenn man das interessante daran.
Das ist übrigens nicht die einzige millionen die die apple mir geklaut hat ne ich.
Ja gut aber was was was was man daran schön ablesen kann ist dass es hier auch mal wieder ein schönes beispiel ist für die soll ich sagen die kommunikationswirt.
Auf der einen seite technischer begriffe und auf der anderen seite gesellschaftlicher begriffe denn,
technisch ist kontext tracing genau das was das telefon dann tut ja weil exposé.
Ja okay also man exponiert sich stimmt also kann man auch so sehen kann man auch so sehen es gibt aber noch ein anderes detail in diesem
protokoll update wo sie auch ein wording geändert haben was prinzip ähnlichen bereich anschneidet und ich hatte da auch schon verwirrte leute auf
auf twitter den ich das dann mal kurz erklärt habe die dann auch wieder beruhigt waren aber die kam dann halt so an ja ich habe mal hier in die protokolle reingeschaut und da steht bei apple ja die ganze zeit etwas drin,
in diesem protokoll gram
und genau so meinte ich so ein ja das ist schon okay das ist halt der technische begriff
für das ausstrahlen eines als anzeigen der vorhanden sein eines dienstes und es hätte halt nicht mit
zu tun so ok danke für die klarstellung und so weiter lustigerweise jetzt in den bluetooth eins eins update haben sie jetzt den begriff würdest mit durch broadcast ersetzt
ja aber das ist klar ne ich meine da sitzen halt sie haben halt irgendwie vierzehn tage lang da die technisch von apple und google in so einen raum eingesperrt und macht mal was oder so ja wir machen contact tracing und wir müssen jetzt wird es mit irgendwie entsprechend rauskriegen stimmt alles technisch
überhaupt nichts dran auszulosen so steht es in.
Protokoll ne aber natürlich in bei dieser app also die exporter dieser dieser projektgruppe gegenüber der weltöffentlichkeit die war dann auch noch ein problem und da arbeiten sie natürlich jetzt entsprechend nach.
Weißt du wo ich glaube sowas auch nochmal irgendwann ins haus steht wenn es nicht schon passiert ist dass ja die epidemiologische.
Ihre in den in der.
Quasi in der verfassung der epidemiologische und der infektionen von valium studien reden.
Ja genau.
Dann hat er denke ich da steht auch noch mal irgendwie so ein so ein fackel mob ins haus ja
wenn die den begriff nicht mal langsam absetzen ja auch der herr trosten verwendet den ja regelmäßig in der und wenn da mal der falsche hin liest dann kommt aber auch direkt
die mistgabel vor der tür.
Ja gut aber da muss dann wahrscheinlich auch die öffentlichkeit ein bisschen lernen so und wir werden sie wie das ausgeht.
Kurz noch was was ich da geändert hat sonst hat sich nicht viel geändert das protokoll ist im wesentlichen das gleiche es gab ja auch noch so eine forderung von diesem die drei p t oder sagen wir mal forderung ist ein bisschen übertrieben aber sie haben sonst einen vorschlag gemacht
wie apple denn da noch das ein oder andere detail
anpassen könnte wie diese all dies ausgestrahlt werden davon ist jetzt erstmal noch nichts zu sehen aber sie haben die crypto ein bisschen geändert und weniger batterie zu verbrauchen sagen sie sie haben deine auch rausgebracht wo sie mal ein paar sachen klarstellen und interessanteste änderungen und
das füttert auch ganz interessant in diese debatte mit,
kann jetzt an welcher stelle eigentlich was gewichten also deine argumentation mit vorteile der zentralen lösung ist ja unter anderem dieses man hat halt mehr
ein blick in das was passiert auf der einen seite und man hat auch mehr möglich.
So ein kontakt oder so eine exposé auch sagen wir mal über die zeit in abhängigkeit neuer erkenntnisse,
besser anzupassen hier gibt es jetzt also auch eine änderung,
war es vorher so dass sie gesagt haben naja die ab die app kann dann sozusagen einfach das system fragen sag mal gib mir mal die
takte die jetzt stattgefunden haben oder die exposés meinetwegen ja und dann war es quasi allein dieses subs systems,
sache dieses subs systems dann einfach zu sagen ja hier sind die kontakte und welche signal stärken dazu einsatz kommen und welche,
dauer so ein kontakt hat um quasi auch als solcher zu gelten war so noch nicht setz,
das ist jetzt in der neuen version nachgebessert worden sprich es fließt etwas mehr einfluss möglichkeit in die app.
Also verschiedene apps verschiedene länder können sozusagen andere maßstäbe heran setzen ohne dass ich jetzt eine gesamte irgendwas verändert hat.
Das ist das ist eine insgesamt sehr gute entwicklung weil wir erinnern uns ja zum beispiel als als ihr wie dieses,
der öffentlichkeit vorgestellt wurde das wurde ja mit zu bildern von von soldatinnen gemacht oder soldaten die da irgendwie in bestimmten in in genannten abständen sich irgendwie bewegt haben,
es ist durchaus ein ein ein großer teil der,
aktivität effizienz der brain power funktionalität einer solchen app liegt eben daran gut zu verstehen welche feldstärken was tatsächlich bedeuten unter welchen bedingungen auftauchen und
dass dann doch der app auch mitzuteilen und ihr die möglichkeit zu geben hier klügere entscheidungen zu treffen.
Oder informierter entscheidungen zu treffen ist der korrekte begriff ermöglicht eben einigen apps hoffentlich auch klügere entscheidungen zu treffen auch da nur weil die app das die entscheidung trifft heißt das erstmal nicht dass sie es besser trifft aber
wenigstens diejenigen die das für.
Angemessenheit mit dir vielleicht ein bisschen mehr hirnschmalz reinstecken wollen können das da tun ist insgesamt denke ich wahrscheinlich eine ganz gute.
Möglichkeit wobei man immer sagen muss jede möglichkeit die apple abgibt bedeutet.
Kann die app besser machen kann es aber auch schlechter machen ne das ist ja der der entscheidende punkt hier.
Ich denke wir werden das lange diskutiert haben,
ob sie das sozusagen machen und wenn ja in genau in welcher form ich würde noch nicht mal sagen dass sie das von vornherein ausgeschlossen haben sondern es ist halt einfach nur in dem ersten entwurf so einfach noch nicht den slash von so machen wir das
erreicht hat was den bereich tokio betrifft hab ich das vor zwei wochen in der ersten analyse bei
auch so schon vorhergesagt und jetzt findet das auch statt so und wer überhaupt mehr lust hat in die totalen details dieser ganzen geschichte mit reinzugehen,
sei auch gerne nochmal auf meine corona weekly mit pavel verwiesen wo ich eben vor zwei wochen dieses dezentrale und letzte woche das zentrale system vorgestellt habe und da werden wir auch weiter.
Dranbleiben.
Dann würde ich da jetzt schon trotzdem wenn du sagst du hast das zentrale system vorgestellt kurz anmerken dass du.
In meinen augen nicht alle vorteile eines zentralen modelles unbedingt fair gewürdigt hast das muss ich schon klar sagen ich bin da
wie gesagt ich bin da sehr bemüht ich kann auch verstehen dass man es nicht macht weil ich habe jetzt die die schlechte erfahrung gemacht wenn da irgendwie ein zitat genommen wird dass man wenn man auch nur ein einziges positives haar an dem zentralen modell lässt ja und da mein vorteil zugesteht dass man dann sofort ins fegefeuer muss
aber es gibt eben das würde ich glaube ich grundsätzlich sagen,
es ist so dass der zentrale ansatz eine reihe an vorteilen für sich geltend machen kann.
Diese vorteile sind hauptsächlich betreffen die,
das logische tracking im prinzip sagen wir mal dieses das was die epidemie logen eben nennen da gibt es vorteile und ich denke,
sowohl tims als auch mein kernargument ist diese vorteile werden aber zu teuer erkauft.
Mit zu viel komplexität mit zu viel datensammlung die in sich wieder ein risiko ist und und um dieses risiko zu erschlagen hat man wieder mehr komplexität und plötzlich hast du eben
ein mamutprojekt dessen risiko modell und trap-modus kaum noch jemand überblicken kann und dass dann irgendwann auch
an dem punkt kommt dass man da nur noch vertrauen muss.
Aber nicht mehr kontrollieren kann und ich denke das ist die die die kernten hatte um die es hier gerade geht deswegen glaube ich sind wir beide ganz klar proportion enten der dezentralen eleganten,
flotten schmalen lösungen.
Absolut was ansprichst der logischen aspekte ich.
Ab zu dem zeitpunkt des podcast das besprochen was zu dem zeitpunkt konkret veröffentlicht war
und nur darauf beziehe ich mich und alles was jetzt jetzt sind ein paar updates gekommen vom projekt jetzt schmeißen die weitere sachen raus wo sie dann vielleicht auch diese vorteile
die sich erhoffen auch nochmal genauer beschreiben weil ich mir auch nochmal genauer anschauen und das ganze ist immer im fluss.
Aber eben auch auf nach wie vor zentrale ansätze auf dem abstellgleis und
ich möchte auch noch eine sache ganz klar stellen weil jetzt auch mit einem offenen brief sehr also,
irgendwie spezifisch das projekt angegriffen wird,
das hat einen zentralen und ein dezentralen ansatz vorgesehen ja das ist also nicht die schuld von peppi dass die bundesregierung auf einen zentralen ansatz pocht und,
leider leider leider ich habe es ja gerade schon gesagt diese debatte entgleitet leider ein bisschen in diese richtung.
Weiter ist die debatte schon in österreich und da gibt's jetzt nur ein kurzen preview weil wir der österreichischen contact tracing app einen eigenen.
Ein eigenes spezial widmen möchten am montag zusammen mit thomas lohn und zwar ist es so dass,
in österreich die app sich angeschaut wurde von epicenter works der von thomas der
also der von max schrems,
research ein security institut was der uni nahe steht und die drei organisationen haben also den quellen der österreichischen contact app bekommen haben sich das,
ich glaube die haben echt eine kurze zeit gehabt ich maximal zwei wochen wenn ich nur eine sehr guten review vorgelegt fünfundzwanzig empfehlungen ausgesprochen sechzehn wurden davon bereits in einem hotfix gelöst ja.
Das ergebnis ist dass auch die architektur jetzt geändert wird auf einen dezentrales system.
Nach modell apple google ja und.
Das ist denke ich hier auch eine eine große erfolgsgeschichte zu zeigen es ist nämlich nicht so dass hier irgendwie datenschutz tötet
stattfindet und hier irgendwelche aluhüte alles verhindern wollen was an so einer app ist sondern dass wir hier
und ich denke das möchte ich für den chaos computer club auch in anspruch nehmen diese lorbeeren dass wir hier extrem konstruktiv.
Versuchen diese gesellschaftliche debatte zu begleiten und das haben hier effizienter und neu und spaß
eben auch getan ja und das mit einem herr herausragenden ergebnis fünfundzwanzig empfehlungen von den sechzehn schon umgesetzt wurden ja das ist denke ich das beste wirken was datenschutz
organisationen und tech in einer solchen situation haben können wo eben ganz klar ist.
Das die gesellschaft dieses contact racing umsetzen wird ja und das denke ich kann man hier nur,
in den höchsten tönen loben übrigens heute wurde glaube ich auch der quelle der österreichischen app veröffentlicht das heißt man kann das sich jetzt auch allgemein einsehen natürlich haben diese ngos die überprüfung unentgeltlich durchgeführt.
Thomas betont ja hier auch immer effizienter works lebt von spenden und die brauchen spenden man kann da also fördermitglied werden.
Denn sonst sieht es nicht so aus als könnte apple santa das jahr.
Aktuell überleben in den shownotes findet ihr.
Die pressemitteilung und den bericht dazu findet auch den link dazu wie man hinter fördermitglied werden kann und am montag machen wir nochmal mit mond mit thomas ein special indem wir uns genau anschauen was da gefunden wurde.
Ja dann
noch ein bisschen aufregung von der man noch nicht so hundertprozentig genau sagen kann wie berechtigt ist die ist oder nicht es gab ja so ein tagesschau tagesthemen interview mit
marietta und unserem gesundheitsminister jens spahn der so in so einem nebensatz als es um apps ging,
auch dann davon sprach man könnte ja dann sozusagen auch zur unterstützung und der kontrolle der quarantäne,
irgendwie apps benutzen da wurde dann im diesem gespräch nicht weiter darauf eingegangen weil das kann man glaube ich dann in dem moment etwas
überraschend und war dem verschachtelte satz vielleicht nicht so ohne weiteres anzusehen welche fragestellung dass jetzt wieder alles aufwirft aber natürlich haben dass leute so mitbekommen ich habe auch gestutzt als das
gehört habe und dachte mir so was kommt jetzt.
Das riecht nach ärger.
Das riecht gut,
weiß man auch noch nicht ich habe kurz einen ausschuss bericht gesehen von anke.
Domscheit-berg die ja für die linken im ausschuss war das jetzt innenausschuss.
Katholischer berg ist natürlich primär erstmal bekannt dafür dass sie bei uns in der sendung zu gast war.
Ja das stimmt ne aber ich habe mir jetzt gerade nicht gemerkt.
War die zweihundert oder habe ich das richtig in erinnerung.
Das war die.
Oder zweihundertsechsundfünfzig nee ich glaube.
Die die die hundertfünfzig hundert die hundert.
Hundertfünfzig war mit nein die hundert war mit christian ströbele die hundertfünfzig war mit julia reda.
Die.
Zweihundert sechsundfünfzig war mit die zwei zweihundert die zweihundert es war die zweihundert sage ich jetzt einfach mal.
Hätten wir das geklärt also daraus kennt ihr sie alle habt ihr euch bestimmt genauso gut gemerkt wie wir hat mir die gelegenheit gegeben kurz nachzuschauen sie ist,
ob frau der linksfraktion im ausschuss digitale agenda und im mitglied in den ausschüssen
zu bildung forschung technikfolgen und verkehr und digitale infrastruktur und ich weiß es nicht ganz genau welche es war wie auch immer auf jeden fall kam dort die information dass es sich hierbei wohl primär zumindest wurden die pläne soweit
angekündigt,
um eine app handeln soll mit der leute in quarantäne so eine art tagebuch anlegen können also die quasi ihren gesundheitsversorgung auf dokumentieren können für die,
gesundheitsämtern vermute ich mal
also das ist noch offen warum natürlich da gleich die warnlampe hochgeht ist natürlich wir hatten das ja auch schon berichtet so wie das so in anderen ländern gehandhabt wird,
holen etcetera oder so so eine so eine fernübertragung mit anrufen und zeigen sie mal ob sie immer noch am selben ort also dass man quasi so beweisen soll dass man auch wirklich ein quarantäne ist
soweit scheinen wir in den planungen noch nicht zu sein.
Also muss es nicht beweisen müssen wir nachher dein tagebuch zur kontrolle vorlegen.
Es geht hier wohl wirklich um den gesundheitsversorgung ich will den jetzt nichts unterstellen wir werden sehen.
Ich dachte die quarantäne etwa netflix aber okay mag was anderes.
Oder disney plus.
So jetzt haben wir da sieht man jetzt nochmal warum.
Wir in der gesamten corona debatte ich kann das nur nochmal wiederholen eigentlich ganz gut laufen weil wir.
Viele überwachungsfans eigentlich aus dem mist rausgehalten haben und es voll überwachung ist immer irgendwie eine einfache lösung vor allem für alles ja und deswegen wird es natürlich auch immer wieder angedreht und angepackt.
Es gibt eine bestimmte ein bestimmtes unternehmen mit dem namen palentin welches von
peter thiel gegründet wurde ein extrem sympathischer junger mann eigentlich weltweit beliebt für seine ausgeglichenen politischen ansichten und seine milden gaben an den.
Us-amerikanischen präsidenten.
Und das unternehmen palentin wurde eigentlich aus dem investment arm der cia ausgegründet ja die,
hauptkunden von parlament hier sind amerikanisches militär und amerikanischer geheimdienst die,
sind dafür bekannt sehr mit sehr großen datenmengen analysen durchführen zu können und unterstützen damit eben die massenüberwachung programme,
der amerikanischen sicherheits- und militär und natürlich verkaufen sie eben teile ihrer angebote auch in den zivilen markt und in hessen.
Wurde jetzt eine data data mining software mit dem namen foundry.
Angenommen ja das genutzt werden soll um daten aus verschiedenen quellen zu sammeln verbindungen zwischen informationen zu ziehen
und so irgendwie bessere einsichten oder was auch immer in die.
Corona situation zu bringen das ist natürlich bedauerlich eigentlich wenn,
hessen dann auf solche eindeutigen ausgründungen und seitenarm e des überwachungs,
industriellen komplexes setzen weil das genau das ist was natürlich problematisch ist ne wir können wir führen auf der einen seite eine diskussion,
über sagen wir mal kontext,
oder exporter tracing mit maximal privatsphäre ansetzen wir arbeiten hier eigentlich als gesellschaft auch konstruktiv auf ein ziel und dann einem unternehmen.
Wie parlament hier das codewort washington zu erlauben also ein eindeutig immer,
böse arbeiten des unternehmen und auch als böse bekanntes unternehmen hier die möglichkeit zu geben auch mal in der in der zivilen legalen
nutzung ein use cases zu bringen der dann eben in der verwendet werden kann ist es ist bedauerlich ja das sind die machen ja auch,
jetzt habe ich leider vergessen heißt nicht dieses dieses polizeiüberwachung programm von denen sogar gosslar oder sowas also die haben auch irgendwie solche.
Historischen namensgebung.
Die haben die haben palentin ist ja auch das kommt doch irgendwie aus herr der ringe oder so dieser begriff das ist auch eine.
Schon so ein bisschen dystopische dystopische begriff ich glaube das hat irgendwie.
Palette genau ja also die haben wirklich das ist da ist der peter ziel sich auch nicht zu schade.
Dann eben da auch gar nicht unbedingt hinterm.
Die palentin singular palentin waren die sehenden steine auch was in die ferne blickt genannt.
Ist doch irgendwas aus herr der ringe oder.
Ja ja das ist jetzt ein zitat aus.
Der allwissende steine.
Aus einem herr der ringe vicky und es ist sozusagen etwas was du in die ferne blickt.
Es ist nicht ganz so desktop sondern tut halt so ein bisschen als würde es in die zukunft blicken vielleicht tut es das auch aber dann vielleicht sind die falsche.
Ja sie trugen auch dazu bei das reich von gondola lange zu behüten und zusammenzuhalten naja und so weiter ich kenne mich ehrlich gesagt eben herr der ringe zu wenig aus und jetzt hier kompetente oder auch nur halbwegs lustige assoziationen herauf zu beschwören.
Also klar ist peter thiel ist sauron ja und man sollte möglichst viele steine eine regel nach ihm werfen.
Nee es ist es ist bedauerlich es ist es ist tatsächlich einfach nur bedauerlich solche unternehmen da einzubringen und es zeichnet sich auch andererseits die hilflosigkeit der gesellschaft wenn dieses,
natürlich in diesem feld der überwachungstechnologien natürlich da die expertise liegt ne.
Gut los ich danke ich denke wir sind am ende.
Ich denke auch.
Wir freuen uns auf montag mit thomas über den den nächsten schwall apps wobei ich wirklich sagen muss mir blutet dieser korona app kram inzwischen aus den ohren.
Und aus dem aus dem mund es wäre jetzt schön da mal.
Jetzt auch einfach nach einer monate diskussion jetzt langsam einfach mal auch eine realisierung folgen zu lassen und,
möglichst schöne datensparsamkeit dann haben wir hier gesellschaftlich einfach auch hand in hand gearbeitet das würde man schönes erfolgserlebnis.
Ich mache dir wenig hoffnung dass diese diskussion bald beendet sein wird die wird es noch eine weile verfolgen ich allerdings hab noch großen spaß daran das zu verfolgen ich werde gerade das war.
Tja was also was was ja bedauerlicherweise passieren wird ist das was.
Also was was ich für defizite in der diskussion feststelle erstens es gibt so eine art halsbringer versprechen die wenigsten leute haben inzwischen sage ich mal die.
Chancen und grenzen des potenzials einer solchen corona app gesehen ja ich habe das ja hier immer wieder versucht zu betonen.
Was kann das leisten was kann es nicht leisten.
Wo sind die wo sind die grenzen und je weiter diese fachdezernaten ich ich habe heute noch leute.
Mit denen ich rede nicht nur journalistin auch menschen wo du sagst so mit deinem background solltest du zu diesem thema.
Solltest du keine schwierigkeiten haben den unterschied zwischen zentral dezentral verstanden zu haben ja oder zu zu verstehen um was es hier überhaupt hier überhaupt geht und es gibt immer noch eine erschreckend weite verbreitung,
von leuten die überhaupt nichts verstanden haben von von all dem was da stattfindet und wenn jetzt hier so,
scheindebatten in der öffentlichkeit stattfinden dann.
Hat das letztendlich nur ein ergebnis und das ist seit vier dort und bei den leuten die eben.
Vielleicht aus verschiedenen gründen nicht in der lage sind oder auch nicht motiviert sind sich da jetzt einzulesen ich finde es auch vollkommen okay dass man sich dass sich menschen hier jetzt nicht alle vollständig in diese auseinandersetzung.
Hinein lesen aber auch die leute die nicht informiert.
Sich informiert meinungen bilden werden sich am ende eine meinung bilden und da müssen
da sind einfach solche diskussionen über schein auseinandersetzungen oder oder irrelevante auseinandersetzungen die an der an der gegebenheiten vorbei diskutieren eben leider,
für niemanden von vorteil.
Nicht hilfreich ja wobei man es auch sagen muss ist es ist auch ein komplexes thema so es ist nicht einfach diese ganzen implikationen zu verstehen ist auch nicht einfach zu erkennen,
wer sind denn jetzt hier eigentlich die waren experten hörerinnen dieses podcast wissen das natürlich aber nicht alle teilen diese erfahrung.
Damit würde ich noch gern dem oliver danken der maren.
Dem axel dem christian und dem tobias die mir in dieser woche große freude bereitet haben.
Wir wünschen euch für ein paar tage noch ein paar schöne tage und dann sind wir auch bald wieder da bis bald.
Tschau tschau.